[Music]
together
look at his life look at what he's done
with that life
[Music]
I learned that uh that together if
somebody with you that believes in you
can get through anything and um and I've
learned that that um
everybody has Parkinson's everybody has
something and to recognize that and to
be honest about it with people and help
them and then in turn help you it's huge
I think about running into him in New
York on the street and just he always
has so much joy and so much
um kindness that's who he is and Tracy
too you know so I I think of that I just
think of like who he is as a person he's
so deserving to be getting this tonight
how old were you when were you did when
you saw a notice Michael J Clark
family you know I I think it was a VHS
of of uh Teen Wolf he was either Teen
Wolf or
the time travel movie oh Back to the
Future Back to the Future is you know
like I saw that movie in the theaters it
was amazing we are talking to literally
a man who grew up in what we call the
Michael J fox economy between TV and VHS
tapes of Michael J Fox's movies you can
watch him again and again and again
I just feel like he was just great on
Family Ties too yeah I mean he really
created a great character that you can
empathize with and even though he was
conservative he's big on Reagan and all
of that he just humanized look at his
work his work just his body of work is
incredible his performances and then how
he has navigated his disease
advocacy
put into it and the amount of money he
has raised all with his humor and spirit
intact he is as great a person as you
could ever want to know